good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast my co-host today has a
same haircut as Jackie a lot loved one
year ago but it's brown it's Darren
she's here she's always here with Jackie
it's like so annoying cuz I just watch
and like I'm screaming at the phone
right cuz I want to get my questions and
for you yeah of course
do people just come up to you on the
street or like well what did Lisa Rinna
say you know mostly though but I'm a
huge toaster fan tell me this isn't
isn't it son like it's so great it's so
nicely wow you're a Bravo encyclopedia
basically well yeah no I think you're
the bravo encyclopedia actually Jackie
is you delete cuz i dimension remember
anything she's meta for season 4 episode
21 Lisa Rinna says I don't know why keep
using glycerin as an example because we
love her she's the most amazing
housewife any interview she is and there
was so much there is so much going on in
the world that I want to talk to you
about but like I got into the day all
roads lead back to Bravo yeah I know you
were like here's five things that aren't
Bravo you're like we have to get your
Bravo sir I was like just Saturday to
bring us back there's so much going on
but what's going on in your life oh my
god I have so much
I am literally so much going on podcast
for martinis and murder we're doing a
live show at South by Southwest you are
okay
I'm over there ninth are you gonna be
there no I get there much as well than
I'll leave March 12th oh the life of a
chest Oh Oh do Street just flying into
Austin every hour
no I know um that's so what are you what
are you just like the panel just
discussing developing businesses and
media look at her it was like her new
it's like other like really actually
accomplished people and I could think
they just like what I mean to be nice
like wanted me to post about on
Instagram you know that's why I'm always
there just suppose about some on
Instagram and I do I love when you tell
me you're near like semi famous people
that like they just want me to post on
my Instagram like it's true it's so
martinis and murder podcast Portuguese
murderer then we're doing the live show
for death becomes us which is a crime
festival in New York City at the end of
March please come if you're here and
then I'm starting to do the videos
behind watch what happens live called
Bravo pregame again so that's why I was
interviewing Rinna I'm doing use and of
all tonight do it in the green room
doing in the green room and then for the
show do a read tomorrow direct
do you only do it the Bravo pregame with
the guests I watch happens live who are
Bravo liberties like I'm gonna do with
Chrissy Teigen well actually
Chrissy Teigen will do it but you know
what I mean yeah I find that bravotv.com
fans really just want more Bravo be
right well like they go to watch her
happens live I think to get like what
julia roberts saying about the
vanderpump dog scenario right but for me
like they just want to know more about
bran what is Julia Roberts saying about
the better pup dog scenario is she
saying anything she's probably not
saying anything because she's like too
cool I'd like to pretty because I like
Mary last night at the Oscars she's the
love of my life is she my girlfriend has
like the biggest boner for her like
loves her loves her lover she's like
she's just an amazing actress she's just
amazing this she is amazing she ladies
like she looks great
oh phenomena like she doesn't look like
she's had any work done and that's the
point
yeah that is the point that's like
that's good work yep right exactly I
don't want to look like I've had work
she was bothering me last night just
because like she was being so like
overdramatic with her mannerisms and the
way that she was speaking when she had
like two sentences to say and also she
had severe dry mouth and the microphone
was picking up the you know this sorry
podcasters ready it's like don't that is
literally for lesbians that's a big
no-no big no-no we don't know we don't
even did you pick up on it last night at
the Oscars only I was at a party I'm
picking up her on now though and that it
was annoying me so much as I drink some
water [ __ ] no it's giving me a PDS she
was thirsty so who were you like really
surprised that you thought like dressed
really well at the Oscars last night oh
I mean I mean I just like the whole
thing was like so weird
I need Kacey Musgraves killed it and the
Daily Mail had to absolute nerve to put
her on the worst-dressed list which just
I'm I love her I love Kacey much I dye
fur and juicy Kyle Richards is like
living for the comparisons people say
they look alike and a lot of people
thought at the Grammy said it was Kyle
Richards no yeah no she loves it and she
was responding to everyone in Twitter
last night like can reach you at the
Oscars huh I mean you like dressing up
would you want to go to the Oscars ifs
almost like here's a free ticket you
don't get this in the front row Oh a
free ticket do you want to go so I had
that offer for the Grammys and I do it
performances great I was gonna say like
I did have severe FOMO yeah um for the
Oscars not so much ah I was thinking
Kacey Musgraves went walked on the red
carpet she was talking all the
interviews how her dress was like so
heavy it was so much and ever had to
make way for the dress and then she sat
out in this little like theater chair
right in this big-ass dress and you
could see her dress literally from every
angle of every seat like anytime they
came to the audience you saw her dress
and it's like I would need to do that
and then put on leggings all right
this on right it's like at a wedding
like after the ceremony's done like then
you put on your flip-flops right exactly
and that's why I just I don't think I
could really ever be like actually
famous I just feel like it would be
horrible like become very boring I was
just watching Country Strong and before
spoiler alert
what if Paltrow commits suicide she
parks some wisdom onto like the new you
know budding country star
supposedly we're supposed to think that
this is the Kelly canter and she's
giving her like all the lists of things
she's like find a way to tell people
about your parents if you ever need
anything it's damaged don't drink
carbonate you kardama tea or whatever
and then she goes wear heels all the
time anyway you go no matter what and
then I'm like I literally kill myself
damn I can never be Kelly canter like
because I'm not ever going to be wearing
heels no those are those aren't heels
right no it's not know I bring literally
like flip-flops with me like from the
nail salon everywhere I go it is just as
important as chapstick like oh yeah you
need it act like I want like a foldable
yeah pop that you could just like fit in
your back pocket that's a good invention
you should make one for Shark Tank
I had an invention that I wanted to run
by you can I pitch you my invention of
course you know what a squatty potty is
of course okay so I have a squatty potty
I actually threw it out yesterday just
because it's so big and it gets so dirty
and it takes up so much space in my
little bathroom I didn't know it changed
my life so like it was really upsetting
for me to have to get rid of it and it
changed my life so much know that I
travel so much right I literally like
will be in hotels or airports or
wherever I'm like I can't go number two
because I need that elevated six foot
sir have your feet up like that so I
started to take garbage cans and put
them under my feet and it works but it's
not great and I was on the airplane and
I was hungover and I really needed I'm
sorry this is really so graphic but I
needed to poo yeah and I just I couldn't
do it one cause I have a phobia of
airplane toilets all I ever want to poop
on a plane I never have I held it in the
whole time yeah but also not having that
six foot six inch surface was also
making it rather difficult right and in
that moment of desperation in this
little bathroom I thought of an
invention okay
and I just sketch of it the mother of
necessity that's how inventions are and
also I know someone could technically
steal the idea but me saying it now is
that means I own the whole property yeah
so picture this it's a foldable it's too
cuz you need one for each foot it's like
a foldable stir-up okay okay so it's
shaped like a stick and then a you on
top okay you just put your foot in and
it's it can holds up to like two or
three hundred pounds it has like a
little like platform at the bottom so it
doesn't fall over it's like a tripod for
your foot
yes oh my god but you get two of them
then you fold him back up it's like air
pods then you put it back in this little
thing and then you start in your purse
that would be okay but it would have to
be really small cause no one's gonna
want to carry around to agree but
especially in an airport you're already
carrying a lot of stuff so like what if
it's the size of a phone I think you're
fine you need to find the difference
between like is two inches off the
ground gonna make a difference or does
it really need any fun it has to be five
or six okay so these are kind of big
tripod Eastern right but they're they do
you come what's the word decompress like
no they collapse they collapse like um
you know those Ray Ban sunglasses that
like you take off and then the eyes fold
like so that's my stirrup that is
actually hilarious guys come if you
would buy it I would really like please
about five people buy it it's so worth
it just to for you to invent something
not even that it's just worth it for me
to have a product I don't need to invent
it for mass production I just need to
make it for myself I think you should do
it but where do you start with something
like this where do I find a factory oh
my god it probably is so easy I would I
would start with like anywhere as a mix
like furniture like little table legs or
like dollhouse little things so that is
tiny and then you just need like a
little tripod and then you can fasten
like a little one to be a partner in my
company yeah demo started inventing
right now you have to promote how much
happens live though and in all your
profits done okay great done that's easy
51:40 well yeah I do demented yeah sorry
very quickly sixty forty sixty forty
sixty forty but I'll promote I'll do all
of it I have and II do a demonstration
done any on the toilet or like any
little baby on the toilet that's so cute
even to watch Andy do a demonstration I
feel like that would be the
highest-rated episode of watching up
inside I think you ever I mean any
product Andy lenses MJ was automatically
like a band gold yeah Autocar what's it
called auto trader auto trader you were
on the commercial yeah it was I was on
three of them
and they're they're still playing that
they play everywhere not just love I
think that they were gonna play this
much thank you never everywhere tell
this to me I'm like a little embarrassed
like gonna be like shop all the cars and
I'm like oh yeah okay so when you did
that like yeah
do they do your hair and makeup like oh
yeah big-time the same woman Carolina
Andy's makeup did my makeup for that
shoot because we shot it at the office
and it was like eight hours to shoot it
was like very Hollywood very hey you
yeah Autotrader pay do how much a lot I
can't disclose the amount but it was a
very good payday for me can you just
close it to me later
yeah I got to you later I'm so nosey
close it to anyone ever I'm always
asking people how much money they make
it's like so [ __ ] rude I will say
well I mean there's all those rules
because you have to like be part of sag
a parter sag oh so when you do I'm like
Instagram like sponsorships in the video
form you get eligible for sag and I look
at that to do it they wanted $3,000 from
membership that's the same but you know
what the health insurance and sag is
like amazing and incredible my
eyeshadows are insane I just got health
insurance I'm off of Bend has been just
turned 26 so until now he was on his
parents plan right and I've been
self-employed since school so I just
like haven't really you know gotten
around to like paying for health care
yeah but now that I'm married and been
torn turn 26
I get his work health insurance and I
just got glasses and my vision test was
ten dollars and Ben has just been
insured forever 85 year old woman and
that if I love you you're like went down
to the public yes it's a godly shirt
then has had amazing insurance forever
so it's not fazed by it right the guys
like that vision test is like $250 a
Mike okay up twenty or fifty dollars for
for peace of mind fine he's like oh but
your insurance let me sue the
calculations ten dollars I was like do
you were contacted every day no I I find
vision like really fine but in like long
distances I can't see like really not
well at all and I do get migraines and I
happen to think that the lack of like
good vision contributes to it all so I'm
just dramatic and I want some I want
glasses like a cute pair like I think
you look really cute no I know and I I
wear Ben wears glasses and I wear like
his old glasses while we're in bed
watching TV or like doing anything like
at the theater et at the theater theater
so I just think it's time that I invest
in my own pair and get like a chic Tom
Ford like round over time something like
even all of our peoples will be good
that's the Bears yeah yeah purse all's
would be nice purse all's
do you wear glasses wear contacts no I
love women and glasses so it's like a
weakness my girlfriend wears glasses
does she well I'm afraid that like I'm
just gonna now rely so much on my
glasses glasses glasses that
one day and eventually need to get
contacts is that how it works I don't
know but think it like maybe you like
handicap your own eyes but whatever
you'll have your contacts in the same
exact case that you have your little
stirrups right there all being compact
on one plate I'm like yeah I love it
you're gonna be fine
and know that I can make like another
business like for women and glasses
right like hot like poop but see while
your self P exactly so it's like a rear
view mirror exactly I like it it's like
a one-woman show for you literally yeah
well now that we've sufficiently we said
enough time yeah I've made you rich I
think I think I'm ready are you ready
I'm ready to talk all things with you
today we are about to jump in to the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast so obviously we
have to start with the Oscars obviously
I'm so much happened here's the complete
list of winners even though like I don't
care do the main ones what were your
thoughts on the first Oscars without a
host I thought it was way better I
thought it flowed more easily like that
they kind of kicked it off with Maya
Rudolph yep Amy Poehler and Tina Fey
because they were funny they were light
heart like a hoist yeah I don't know
like I like the speeches and sometimes
there's great speeches but sometimes you
just drag on for too much and then just
like you know you know what it's like
wanting a show it's like let's keep it
going let's keep it going like well I'm
on come on come on come on I usually
have not here for the hosts but I did
think like just given what has happened
in the past like we have two weeks
there's so much opportunity for fodder
and imagine just imagine for one second
Kevin Hart had hosted and was talking
about Jordan and Kyle a must see
Smollett like there's just so much going
on in the world for him to poke fun at
it would have been a really good the
truth is is like if you host the Oscars
you can't win are Kelly
yeah there's but like could you touch
that like I don't know Hollywood's very
very sunny when it was so interesting
yeah I'm rewatching entourage and first
of all the first season I think is 2006
like it's really a different world they
say the words f AJ yeah and re T ard
literally six times per episode it's
crazy
oh yeah and I remember watching it the
first time I'm not thinking anything of
it and now in the first episode he's
like yo you retorted I was like what I
know it's really like it was a different
lifetime but there's a scene where are
each of Viagra and then his wife leaves
because she has mad at him or something
he goes I'm harder than are Kelly at
recess
uh but that's the thing they like those
jokes you might have been too young like
I remember the P tape no like I remember
when all that stuff came out and it was
just like in the ether no one like did
anything about it but think about it
this was a joke in 2008 I want to say
yeah we're like he was so very much like
pop in and cool 100% I mean up until now
like so shocked I can't believe our
Kelly really cuz Ari Gold they'll write
like Mark Wahlberg now I think it's a
little bit like Oh Hannibal Buress like
called out Bill Cosby it was yes in the
ether but yeah no one really said
anything that's like on Family Guy now
if you go back and watch except
MacFarlane has been calling out like
Harvey Weinstein and so many people they
were Spacey forever forever they've been
doing it just no one's been paying
attention it's crazy so I just really
would have liked Kevin Kevin Hart is so
funny I would have loved just to hear
his father even though like given what
had happened to him and then like given
Jessie smell it like pretending to have
been the case right forgive for being
gay and black I just I don't think Kevin
Hartman may have been the best person to
start joking about it no probably not
Jesse Smollett his like ruined it for
the game black community
Jesse's know that has ruined my life you
know like I thought it was actually a
hosted a hoax at first like that's the
problem with it I know we're switching
to that subject right now but like I you
know what you're like scared to say
something what's that like I've been
hate-crimed before so I had you yeah by
an ex-girlfriends mother oh is that the
what's in Andy's book yeah that like
threatened my life with a shadow zone or
whatever I mean like I guess that's
considered a hate crime even if it's
verbal like totally emotional abuse
counts and like I don't know that was a
real thing I went through so when you
see someone a victim and I'm gay go
through it you're like oh my god this is
horrible but you're like who cares a
noose around its Who I am like right is
this bleach I don't know we saw this
Subway sandwich in his hand the cops
came like something's not adding
to like investigate I feel like no
where's your responsibility on like
reporters these days so like dude that
kind of work but everyone is so
sensitive like you would never ever want
to accuse someone of who's a victim of a
hate crime of making it up right and so
what's what's the what's like the
solution there we say like if this is
true its horrable but then that's like
so insulting right is it true
oh you denying that
my experience right so which it's hard
either way and that's why I was like I
don't want to say that it's well just
imagine if it wasn't a hoax and I was
like this is a horrifying lost my job
horrifying what's my job so we're gonna
get into that in a little bit but here's
a list with list of winners of the
movies that actually matter for Best
Picture did you see all the best
pictures no I only saw stars born
I only saw that in favorite what did you
think of the favorite I actually really
liked it I thought it was a really good
period piece I mean obviously the
lesbian undertones really great for me
Oh what's the lesbian I don't even know
what it's about
basically Rachel Weisz and Emma Stone
are so the queen is like Olivia Colman
she won last night yes and she her like
companion like sidekick like basically
ride-or-die like me for Andi is Rachel
Weisz and you find out that Rachel Weisz
has been like hooking up with Olivia
Colman this whole time sure and then
Emma Stone comes in as like her kind of
servant and then seduces Olivia Colman
and then they're kind of in this weird
like love triangle in like we 13
hundreds or whatever it is weird it's
pretty cool and what's Joe all wins role
I mean just like another person okay I'm
not major it's so weird that Joe Olin of
it all it's so okay so green book one
yeah I did see it
bended and like Ben is not like into
movies and he could not stop talking
about how it's the best maybe he ever
saw and they all like the little teasers
for it made me really want to see it I
heard it's like Driving Miss Daisy
except the white guy's driving the black
guy
I don't know Driving Miss Daisy ain't
never saw it okay it was a very popular
film like bagging well yeah yeah Green
Brook was popular too it won't have to
see it okay um blah a star was born did
not want actually thought Black Panther
was gonna win II thought yeah I didn't
see it me neither but Ben saw it I don't
mind like speaking their back from the
studio Ben is like Black Panther it's
the best movie ever saw in his life and
when he can't I remember it came out a
long time ago and when he saw it and he
came home like he was invigorated with
new life like he was just non-stop
talking about it Black Panther was
Wakanda forever right yes yeah that's
what Ben said 200 I don't know what I
think about nothing or some reason even
okay what Best Director winner was Roma
yeah I'm a notable loser was Spike Lee
yeah and I music never won well so he
won last night for adapted screenplay
right I know that but he was on Ryan
Seacrest and he was just like yeah this
is my first nominee
or whatever and he was like it's a sham
like I should have been nominated a long
time ago and I usually hate when people
do that like be grateful but I do kind
of agree like he's this iconic director
and he's never been nominated for an
Oscar but at the same time wouldn't you
think that Spike Lee would like hate the
Oscars yes he's so like he's a Bob Dylan
of it all we give a [ __ ] I won the Peace
Prize then when greenbook won Best
Picture he like turned around and
refused he put his back to the to the
Cavs immature like that's so stupid
you're already so wealthy you're already
sitting at this like the peak event of
LA and you're turning your back in the
front row and like he got so many
shoutouts I suspect Lee was like the
star yeah right he always is the star um
best animated feature film spider-man
who cares foreign language film Roma
which is so crazy oh my like swept I
didn't see it but like now I have to
even though some Netflix with my bad
vision I can't watch movies with
subtitles Best Actor in a leading role
role rami malek for Bohemian Rhapsody
yeah which I didn't see I didn't see but
I plan on seeing it but what you didn't
see on the Oscars which I only saw when
I was looking for stories this morning
is yeah when he got offstage at during
the commercial break he fell and the
EMTs had to come like take care of him
that's literally why I watch the Oscars
see a trip they have paparazzi there so
there's so many paparazzi photos of him
like feelings looking so shocked getting
treated by emergency services like
obviously I think like oh he's a drug
drug addict yeah but like I'm sure he
just felt like it's just the pre-staged
you know know right and everyone's like
wearing gowns that are like right and
4000 it's easy to trip on a wire what
were your thoughts on him just like
making out with his girlfriend so hard
when he won I mean listen get it I think
it's a staged relationship feel like
it's too convenient like for the press
you know you don't think he's gay you
don't think he's like no I just think
like they just like are like Kristen
Stewart Rob Hansen like it's just
convenient for them today I mean she did
end up BJ but like that's not what I was
saying I just meant like more of like an
Orchestrator really Vanessa Hudgens Zac
Efron Yeah right most relationships I
feel like are staged
yes in that way Olivia Colman won for
best I didn't know her but honestly she
delivered the best speech I've ever seen
in my life she was hysterical she was
hysterical and I loved her from
broadchurch I've ever seen broadchurch
on BBC it's like this detective show
she's just like a class act she is
lassie did you see um what's her name uh
the girlfriend logistic and whisky
commercials from SNL
Cecily strong yeah I like sausage
she played Olivia Colman in like a skate
last weekend it was so funny because
it's like she's everywhere this award
season but like nobody knows who she is
right she's like British right that's
what the role was it was really funny oh
that's great Best Actress in Monroe
Olivia Colman best actor at Mahalo Ali
yep love a green book yes Best Actress
in a supporting role Regina King won her
first and I can't believe that she
didn't win for Legally Blonde
I can't blame Sheen and win first
cinderella story and I believe she
didn't win for Miss Congeniality -
gorgeous gorgeous hilarious
it's just by geniality she's Sam fuller
like she's been in so many iconic roles
and like this is the one they reward her
for even though that movie does look
great but like really she was totally
looked over for a Cinderella story no
she's been looked over time I quite a
bit but she looks cool I mean she was
snatched
she looks great me and this would be and
Jackie were saying like she was such a
good actress in Legally Blonde yeah red
white and blonde that I cannot think of
her as anything other than grace like
she will always in my mind to be Grayson
who's Sally Fields little [ __ ] and then
turned on like she could be in
Schindler's List and you're like what no
no grace exactly yeah well that's how
good of an actor she is that's fair yeah
that's fair so overall it was a boring
night everyone left glam but like math I
don't care about award shows enough
anymore maybe like they're just a huge
circle jerk for Hollywood where it's
like saying this to my girlfriend last
night and I know I'm like I'm the old
one here but I'm like wouldn't it be
cool if we had an award show for like
people who invented like DNA replication
like twenty three Emmys stealing our
yeah right like actual like Scientific
Revolution as opposed to like oh they
did a really good job in this field no
they're all just like it's so self
congratulatory it's such [ __ ] it's
an entertainment saying this right true
I'm just kind of like I'm not learning
anything and I feel like it only it
applies to all award shows but the
Oscars in particular because they take
themselves so seriously and it's like
are you kidding me like you made more
money in two months of work than most
people do in their whole lives and now
you're complaining gonna get an award
for it 100% it's such a joke everything
is just like so buttoned up and so and
we Andy and Anderson did a show at the
Dolby Theatre which is where the Oscars
were and that theater is like bare
minimum bare bones in or that have Wi-Fi
they're like the people who run the
Oscars have to pay for why right for
everyone in the room like they take them
it's just like the event they won't give
you anything no extra whatever and it
just it's crazy no I want to talk about
one more thing that I'm sure you can't
really speak on because you are a an
employee
NBCUniversal you have to talk about the
giuliana rancic of it all because
honestly yeah for that interview she
gave with Bradley Cooper she should be
fired can you walk me through the
interview so she couldn't get it her
sentence out and I was appealing for
because I'm sure it's intimidating
and the sentence it's not like it's her
first time right but he it's probably
her first time interviewing him like if
he doesn't show up anywhere and it's
like his night and she was obviously
like really emotionally affected by the
film and she was trying to get her
sentence out for like 25 minutes and
watching him watch her was even more
painful right but the sentence that she
was trying to get to was so awkward she
was just like a star is born' made me so
emotional and it really made me fall in
love with my husband even more which is
like why does someone suffering from
addiction make you love your husband
everybody else right like I don't know
um I was just confused by the whole
thing yeah right but what she said was
like how does it make you feel to know
that you have that effect on people and
it was obviously like a very wordy way
and roundabout way of just getting to
this weird question that already was a
weird question he was like finally when
she gave him the microphone he was like
wow I don't know great and then she
interviewed Lady gaga and figured out
how to ask the question in a much
shorter way and Lady Gaga's I'm like oh
thank you so much for saying that like
Giuliana's just being a thirst monster
[ __ ] general and she was bothering me
so much and she couldn't get a word out
like she was megyn kelly on the
teleprompter like couldn't speak flub
City so you don't like her in general
well I don't know I don't like her yeah
okay well Lisa did you like a stars born
okay put it down and like yeah put my
thoughts on a star is born yes it was
definitely a good movie like from I
entertaining I enjoyed it
I loved music I loved Bradley Cooper I'd
love Lady gaga not the only iteration
you've ever seen yes okay so when people
are referring to it as this like
enormous Lee an important film it's just
like no I didn't see that I just thought
like a good musical right me too
especially for Lady Gaga she was [ __ ]
phenomenal and she destroyed she
deserved to win for shallow her singing
was amazing her acting was very good for
a first-time actress like it was not
Oscar worthy like the fact that she got
nominated honestly like I didn't think
she deserved it and I stand her but I
see it from Strictly an artistic point
of view right where it's a great movie
it's no better than Country Strong it's
the same premise it's it's the same
premise we've seen like oh wow right now
it just it wasn't this like important
cinematography you know
I'm moral to it at the end of it wasn't
like this is gonna change the way that
men's you win right or whatever people
acting like it's this whole important
yeah achievement for our generation like
no I didn't see that I saw a good
musical where Lady Gaga I looked
snatched yeah I feel like Black Panther
is more that then stores is jean black
pants but there was a message right
exactly was important for a lot of
people who saw themselves represented no
I didn't see it I didn't see myself
represent and I just it was good she
wrote a great song she deserved to win
it but she didn't deserve to be
nominated and she certainly I don't
think deserve to win a bunch of the
awards that she did win so much sense
that she was nominated and that's like
when lala land one whatever two three
years ago whenever that was like when
burr when they announced it was lala
land but then it was really like
moonlight that was like one of the
greatest days of my life I mean it was
snot and I don't know yes it was funny
but I was also like if Lowell and wins
like literally the movie industry was
dead to me cuz ya just thought it was so
bad like I thought it was bad she oh but
we're in a minority I know like everyone
crapped all over me for hating it they
were like how could you not think this
was like so important and like no I was
like they're dancing and not that well
then right great I don't know they were
not well and they were not they were not
well and I love them I stand like I love
her for lala land I didn't think it was
a good movie but I saw a lot of things
that like they were you mean it was
unique dancing was really like the
choreography they filmed that whole
first scene on a real highway like there
was a lot of things that were impressive
about it as a storyline I didn't love it
and the acting was like yeah but I there
were parts of it that I thought were
like the special effects were definitely
cool like yeah there were parts of it
that I found impressive and I do
understand how someone could like it
right people acting like been giving
this reverence towards a star as we're
like that I don't get I don't get that I
kind of want to Glenn Close to win and I
like Olivia Colman but just like I feel
like one closely deserved Glenn Close
has never won an Oscar T never has been
she's I think she's the most nominated
though and so when I never have Amy
Adams also has never won one she's a
babe
I feel like the time might have passed
out for her to have won one like we are
where there were like us like a stream
with like five years maybe like five
years ago where she was in every like
banger maybe like American hustle yeah
yeah yeah she was it was just like year
after year now she's just in movies that
like get nominated that I've never heard
of she's in like high-end in
film yeah she's like more of an artist I
feel like she's not like making money
now but she was amazing and sharp
objects not that it was a film but she
was like did you ever see cirno's in HBO
but she was nominee for a Golden Globe
for that right so yeah she was
incredible and the never side she could
be like she can she can do TV and film I
just like she's so diverse she seems
like a very down-to-earth she seems like
she actually doesn't give a [ __ ] that
she have an Oscar look I will say and
again I know that I work at Bravo but I
do like the celebrities that are famous
without making celebrity their first job
like that's why I like Olivia Colman cuz
it's like no one who's know so much but
she's like a real person who does her
job she's like I'm working I'm literally
the polar opposite yeah you love just
Kim Kardashian
celebrities for being famous of course
famous for being famous of course
exactly what speaking of Kardashians
yeah we have a developing story from
last week okay I need your opinion
Chloe appears to call Jordan woods a
snake in her latest cryptic message
Khloe Kardashian is continuing to send
Jordan woods interest in Thompson
messages after not so cryptically
addressing the ongoing cheating scandal
last week in her Instagram stories Khloe
has returned to social media to
seemingly call out 21 year old Jordan
and 27 year old Tristan once again
Tristan to the 27 no totally your babies
so she put up an inscription that said
no matter how much a snake sheds skin
it's still a snake I
I love the cryptic Instagram it's like
cryptic but it's also like not subtle at
all no right exactly like everyone knows
what she's doing and then also just one
more development is Mike Fleiss who is
the producer of The Bachelor yeah has
been like surf singing up on Twitter
he's always being thirsty on Twitter
like a couple seasons ago he had 60,000
Twitter followers and he was like I will
tell you who the bachelor is when you
got me to a hundred thousand followers
that was like three years ago he
literally has 80,000 followers like he
never got to the hundred thousand he's
so [ __ ] thirsty it's so
annoying everyone was like so yeah right
so now he's like bandwagoning off the
kardashian thing and never been rumors
before though I Khloe Kardashian would
be the Bachelorette even though like
it's so not true
that would never happen so he's tweeting
like I'm on the phone with Christian
we're gonna make it happen and you know
these morons on Twitter are like what
yeah even though like it's obviously not
[ __ ] true Kim replied and was like
this is fake [ __ ] news and he replied
like oh him obviously doesn't know that
I've been working with Kris like really
furthering like he's digging his heels
in on
that's that's a thirst trap yeah he's
like really trying to get himself
involved so Khloe tweeted and they put a
screenshot of a group chat between Chris
Kim and khloé being like Chloe are you
doing the Bachelorette and Chloe was
like absolutely not like please I'm more
respect than that yeah like please dear
God no she doesn't mean so in a million
ways are like not addressing what's
going on but like addressing everything
I mean two things with this one isn't
like Kylie really the victim here cuz
she like lost her absolute best friend
everywhere and over to what is with the
Kardashian women choosing like the worst
men like is it just me or I'm like
there's gotta be a good-looking nice
businessman right out there that can
handle the fame they say it's the
Kardashian curse when in reality like
these men were cursed to begin with you
know I mean like I don't know if it's
our Kardashian and listen Lord Disick
like offers high entertainment value I
it's a Danielle style of our generation
like I get that like I want to watch him
on TV but just as like a husband yeah
like how could that I don't know and all
that I mean Kanye seems to be like off
the radar now I feel like Kim like
really like cool to town Chi bashed him
on that have you been seeing their
Sunday churches no okay so for the past
couple weeks months actually
every Sunday Kim has been videotaping
this like huge Gospel Choir like in this
neon lit room that is apparently her
living room and they've been like making
their own church and then yesterday they
did it outside and Kanye was and he was
like leading this choir and it was
honestly amazing like it sounded and
looked incredible they were all there
just like that they're very religious
and they always go to church but now
they're making their own charge a really
religious yes they all in not religious
spiritual ok spiritual okay yeah cuz I
was anybody that's such a conflict for
me yeah Creedy your own church those
sounds a little crazy like coltie but it
also sounds like why you're so right you
don't have to go to church just make one
in your house no right I mean they hire
their own fire department like right did
that but like gospel singers would be
the only reason I'd go to church no I
mean I think that I am a gospel singer
and in some ways I kind of am like the
Jewish gospel that you could be the
first comedian Jewish gospel singer in a
choir to it listen album like a gospel
album you know and I think you should
start like and I would start with that
song from its Sister Act
of course Oh
happy yeah started low oh happy and then
we build it up to like when Jesus washed
when Jesus washed he washed my sins away
and then I'm also out of a bad voice no
I'd let her have the most amazing voice
oh you're not really saying I sing at
Jackie's wedding wait what did you say a
Jackie's coming home from Country Strong
no I mean I have the most amazing voice
I would also have like like the leading
gospel director come in and restructure
shallow into like a gospel version for
would you wear one of those like cool
robes
okay so flattering yeah you have to be
spiritual yeah and I'm just wearing but
comfortable we're leggings underneath
you know yeah never a heel no undies
no no undies no bra no one gets it no
let it all live your graduation gown
it's God's suit for you make sure you
let it all hang on to me like the way I
was born Yeah right exactly a star and
boring dad okay so what are your
thoughts on this Chloe short interest
interest
I mean honestly I struggle because like
I respect the Kardashians for what
they've done but I'm also like so sick
of them that it's like really hard to
care like I will say at first I was like
this is just a PR stunt right like who
in their right mind Jordan meaning
Jordan and granted she's 21 so she's
right would do it who would be that this
is so stupid
no one could be worth this I'm agree
more she's so popular she has to all the
ins are Kylie gave her her entire life
like she could meet another famous cute
basketball football right he's very
sizeable in her world absolutely this
isn't that so much like famous rich guy
that's ever found her a trap but I guess
not so much anymore because I have a
child together and that's like you
you're tied no I mean for Jordan's
standpoint like why own it why ruin it
on this guy no clue why would you ever
go for not only Chloe's guy but a guy
that's in the car - right world
well there's conflicting rumors that
either they've been together for about a
month which obviously makes it so much
more terrible than I thought Jordan
admitted they're not animated they're
like oh why it's just like eonline and
their sources have been saying that yeah
but then this morning I saw a bunch of
reports at like semi-legitimate places
saying that it was like a blacked-out
makeout sesh and like if you're gonna
throw your whole life away for a
blacked-out makeout session they say
that she doesn't really drink so like
when she does it's really bad that's why
she doesn't drink and also if she was
like in trench in
a month-long affair like her and Kylie
are so close like there was no way she
would've been able to hide it
yeah I don't underst I don't understand
with how you know I hope you do watch
handmade still no okay so it's like
there's a saying under his eye like I'm
always like the Kardashians are under
his eyes oh yeah every time they burp
like the world knows about it so if
you're gonna do this huge cheating
scandal which is seems like extremely
harsh how do you get away with that
right like highly was not even really
able to keep her pregnancy under wraps
like everyone pretty much knew and thank
God that true is so young that hopefully
all this stuff will be like the you know
900th story that's good about them
because like if you grew up knowing that
your dad did that right that like as a
child as a human being like that's
really hard that's a really hard
emotional response as a as a child I
also feel like in so many ways like life
works in weird ways and I see Khloe here
as just like this little Jo idea and she
isn't able to get pregnant for so long
and like you know what she got the baby
and that's literally all that matters
like Tristan can eat grab a spoon and
eat her ass yeah I mean I or not because
he doesn't deserve figuratively he
doesn't hit everything I mean to be fair
Khloe kind of knew the person she was
right up with this is his second at lea
second time that we know about I'm sure
there's more right when there's smoke
there's fire so she kind of knew I kind
of like Kylie has just been thrown for
like a complete loop right and Kylie you
got to see a little bit of this on life
of Kylie but she is so invested in her
friendships more so than Oh in her
relationships with her family like I
think she really considers like those
four or five friends that she keeps
around her like closer to her than her
actual family I feel like she was the
most real around Jordan and now that's
completely gone I'm actually not sure it
is yeah she has no one else that she
could trust because when you bring
someone in even before you're famous and
you're so close and you're eight you
only have they probably only have like
three people that they can ever be
themselves truly in front of yeah
because they're not in front of the
cameras people though they can make fun
of people right and do this and now he
was one of them people like I think are
confused a lot as to why Kim and the
Kardashian clan have remained so close
with Jonathan Cheban right like at the
end of the day like he's been tried true
and loyal forever and like yes he like
thirst out on Instagram but like I would
do and he's never been disloyal like
right he loves that meal at that level
like you can't afford to be friends with
people for any reason other
the fact that they would they remain
loyal to him they don't sell story
suppressed and you can't buy loyalty so
that's it it has to be someone that was
there from you with you from the
beginning and she was yeah when she was
a fetus they were they were together so
I actually kind of do feel bad for Kylie
because that has to be I feel very
promising for her Lee I mean Jordan like
moved back in with her mom right yeah
it's just like this sad sad this saddest
emotion but I've also just proved how
much she had riding on this relationship
like well that's a day like you're so
stupid good job if everything worked out
from what we know to be the case like
let's say all of this is true she's
literally the dumbest person in the
world alive I would never have sex with
another person again just astray
entirely Yeah right like just to stay
and Kylie's cafeteria chastity belts
hundred I wouldn't even look at another
woman ever again well speaking of people
who need to wear chastity belt yes our
Kelly can't afford to post MIT bail
after judge sets a million dollar bond
and he remains in Chicago Jail so our
Kylie's attorney says the singer doesn't
have the $100,000
okay Oh literally it was I think a
hundred thousand dollar bail and then
they pushed it up because I thought it
was 100 because I was gonna say
entertainment online the title says a
million dollars and then the text says
the singer doesn't have the hundred
thousand dollar bail he needs to post
CBS Chicago reports Kelley will spend
another night in jail where he's been
removed into a private cell are Kelly's
bond was set at a million dollars on
Saturday what's the difference between
bond and bail I have no idea maybe only
have to post a portion of the guy think
there is only part of it and then
eventually to pay it back cuz obviously
you don't get just because you're
arrested and indicted doesn't mean you
go on trial tomorrow right it takes
months and months and months and you
can't just be like willy-nilly out doing
what you want about time if I ask you
how old are Kelley was what would you
say because our venom shook 47 he's 52
yeah that makes it's like so much
grosser I mean not that it wouldn't be
gross even if he was 47 but there's
something about writing 50 it's not yeah
dude your old dad like our Kelley was
charged with aggravated criminal sexual
abuse against four women including three
minors Steve Greenberg Kelly's attorney
issued a statement late Sunday night rqo
Kelly's spirits are good Kelley's
expected to bond out tomorrow Monday lol
not right now he's being held in the
hospital area of the jail for security
reasons he's not sick or suicidal
it's easier for the sheriff and more
secure that he's not in general
population Kelley will be in court
around 10:00
Eastern Time it should be released
shortly afterwards there's something so
satisfying about him not being able to
like yes I'll whatever that's amazing
did you watch all six parts of course I
mean it's the thing that bothered me the
most about it was the sparkles niece was
like the girl you're not idiot or
whatever and then her parents like
wouldn't even admit it was her like they
still they still are close with our
Kelly I know obviously they're being
paid off right of course that's that's
the whole crux but but the well has run
dry he great longer afford to pay people
off he can't even afford his own bail so
I wonder if that'll affect people coming
out of the woodwork what's so shocking
about this so is that Joycelyn and
Azrael who have two girls at the like
the last couple episodes yeah his
parents were there they've been trying
to get in contact they showed up to
court to support our Kelly they showed
up there's still technically in his cult
like they're so brainwashed or whatever
that so they say so they showed up to to
support him like there's one thing about
being seduced and like manipulated when
you're 14 17 especially with someone
who's so famous right like so rich but
like as a parent I did you much abducted
in plain sight oh no thanks I can't
watch it like that oh okay well if any
of you have watched it it was like the
parents are like I felt like how great
be so dumb I know oh my god that's the
thing like we're not even thinking about
it
it's horrible children when there were
so many there were so many allegations
out against our Kelly already and then
those parents sent there remember they
had the two daughters and the daughter
went to go get the younger daughter and
got beat up
they are Kelly told him Cole told the
parents say we're gonna get a chaperon
from the from the label like they're
like okay our Kelly's getting a chaperon
I'm like are you [ __ ] kidding me this
throw I don't throw a thirteen-year-old
kid in the car and like sure let's go to
at least you know come back like aren't
you questioning why he wants to hang out
with your 14 year old kid like Kelly at
recess but they also it's all of our
faults too because his sales skyrocket
director that like everyone's complicit
if you're still supporting this guy I
mean the fact that he's gotten away with
it for so long is fascinating to me and
if you think of all the people who were
had to have
to hand in making this whole thing
happened yeah if you think about just
the girls going you know from house to
the airport the people driving them the
managers the assistants like and
everyone knew there's so many people who
were complicit I mean that's what's even
scarier like the innocent bystanders his
older brother who I think is in jail
because it seemed like yeah they did I
was the brother and yes but he was like
in a gel suit and the gel was behind him
yeah like it was obvious but they didn't
also say why he was in jail so bright he
seemed to be most accepting of his
brother well that's what was so funny
right I'm like jail and then he had
another brother who was like a good guy
and r.kelly [ __ ] blamed yeah they
said it's my brother in the video peeing
on the girl like I wasn't it true though
that he that he was molested when he was
a kid yes older woman and they said it
was ants or something it was that's why
they had the three brothers in the
beginning saying they were all that's
why he has a thing with like little
girls and so okay listen I do a podcast
on about murder right and so there's
like a lot of sick twisted things that
happen in the things that we talk about
and in one hand it's like nature nurture
like do I think Erik Kelly was born that
way probably not like he probably wasn't
born child molester or like into little
girls but obviously like some wires got
crossed obviously he had two tragic
childhood and that turned out to be that
so you're like do I feel sympathy for
them know at some point no like it would
be one thing if he was 21 struggling
with this at 52 and you're making
millions upon millions of dollars and
you're manipulating an entire world
about this no [ __ ] you I hate you no let
go to jail forever and I like I kind of
hate when movies or documentaries like
try to humanize like monsters I know
you're like supposed to and it's
important to it's just a bad story it's
sorta like people aren't born child
molesters like you said so like it's
yeah but I don't know it's just like
please [ __ ] that will eventually have to
take responsibility for your actions
right like I'm born as smart or as dumb
as I'm going to be like the difference
between right and wrong
what do you eventually have to like
learn to read and like wanna be on your
own like regular yourself like the fact
that our Kelly couldn't read I was like
will that make sense right that's funny
I know I mean she was just like I was
like I just want you to be that little
boy who admit they couldn't read
she was so sad that at the ex-wife who
she had kids with well that's because
she's probably like I'm bonded to him
for life it's not just me like imagine
his whole children half of him and do
they even speak up about it my daughter
or the daughter said something she's
like you have no idea what it's been
like to like know who the monster that
is your father right especially girl
right I'm like and like it's conflicted
because like you are half of this person
right so do you hate half yourself right
it's it's like this is in me term it's
in me it feels bad so many terrible
things going on in the world yeah our
Kelly 2020 it must be small it and I
don't know if you're keeping up why we
keep calling him I see it's because he
staged his own hate crime and it was it
was extremely messy about it so he's now
a messy small F that makes sense I mean
writing a personal check like with his
name in the top of no I mean like he
literally wrote in the memo basically
like hate crime to myself like staged
hate crime any hoax I just love that he
paid those guys thirty five hundred
dollars like a piece and they were gonna
go to jail like for the rest of their
lives like throw so that's why when she
views himself he's like seven thousand
dollars of me that's that's what that's
how I value myself so the core of why he
did this was that he was really unhappy
with his salary right at twenty thousand
dollars in episode so you're just gonna
fork over seven grand that's half an
episode almost it's just so I mean he
literally ruined it for everyone I mean
a lot of times like that's how I felt
like when all the mean to stuff was
coming at her and still coming out and
like the Aziz Ansari thing which I
didn't think was the same thing as like
a me to I was like okay Aziz Ansari's an
[ __ ] right I don't want to go on a
date with him right but he didn't like
sexually assault anybody you know they
were so different I was just reading
something about that because I remember
when it came out it was on some like
fake website yeah like that was not
legit and then there was a New York
Times op-ed yeah that was kind of like
saying everything that people were
thinking it's like the only thing is
he's Ansari is guilty of is not reading
people's minds is being an [ __ ]
so yeah like this girl was giving a lot
of nonverbal cues but like for a guy
who's on a date and just wants like get
laid like that might not be like your
number one and it should be but it's not
your number one concern to be like if
she blinking like is she subliminally
trying to say something and he's guilty
of being an absolute freak like putting
his hands in people's mouths stop and
Oprah said I'm he's guilty of being an
ass for sure it wasn't just being like a
celebrity douche yeah I don't know I
but so they didn't kidnap her and forced
her back to her ng Kaling just went to
his show or something and put up the
tickets on her Instagram was like the
show was great and the comments were
flooded with just like how could you I
thought you were a tally of women and I
feel like when I speak on this like you
can't say the right thing like I really
have a kind of attack right now for what
I said it means you owe me too so I
don't know what the right thing it's but
it's not the same thing my point is like
it's not the same thing as Harvey
Weinstein no it's not the same thing as
bar Kali right he's not drugging people
he might have had a really bad date and
I have the wrong signals but like a lot
of humanity is feeling out how other
right like and like oh so many when this
happens like what someone accuses Harvey
Weinstein like 10 other people show up
and they're like yeah hashtag meet
exactly what no one else is saying about
this like it's weird
well yeah and like okay we're leaving it
back to Bravo below deck Adrian the chef
like I would make these kind of like
sexual comments to some people right but
she never spoke up she never said one
thing about it and like he wasn't being
grabbing he was just like oh I've got
your meat right here like ill be an
[ __ ] being stupid boy jokes but like
again not eternity being like the
comforter bro right but she should have
also said something and for my opinion
it's like okay if I'm a woman and
someone says like Oh dare and your boobs
look great no one ever say that cuz I
have no clue but let's just say in
theory someone said that about me if
that made me uncomfortable like dude
don't say that about me it makes me feel
uncomfortable and then if you continue
saying it that's where I am that's
harassment that's harassment
you're an [ __ ] but it up until that
point it could just be your vibe in that
body you're human and it also just
depends on the person right it depends
on the person like if someone said to me
your tits are great I'll be like yeah
you take a looks big right that's just
but that's you and I know that I'm
anything that exactly not every single
person would say that and I was like
sexually like comfortable just like
being a freak yeah and I feel like we
should be promoting especially women to
like speak up for themselves like what
you're trying to be uncomfortable don't
let it be like oh the man should read
your mind
no you're making yourself the victim no
matter what and the guy can't read
anyone's mind and you know what I'm a
flirty person and I like women like I
make the jokes and if you tell me it's
uncomfortable I will stop making those
jokes do you find that as a gay woman
like when you tell straight men that
you're
they like get gross they get like really
into it like if I want to get a guy away
from me at a bar like if me and my
girlfriend together will say that we're
sisters are like best friends because
which obviously leads them to maybe want
to hit on us but saying that we're
together in a relationship makes it 10
times worse like they say like oh you
just haven't met the right guy you're
like oh really the first what's the
first date I ever went on with my
girlfriend Carson we were at a bar and
these cops started hitting on us and
really gave fake names and this is our
first date and she's looking at me and
she's like I'm an alum she's like she
basically is like I want to get out of
here and let's say we have to go to the
bathroom you're sick so I was like oh
I'm not feeling when they go to bathroom
she's gonna take me and we they guys
like kept pounding on the door we were
like an hour we had our first kiss in
the bathroom oh that's so cute
yeah but like because we were both
equally terrified of what was out there
right they view it as I mean not
everyone that a lot of men view it is
like this is an accomplishment like I'm
gonna tackle this right hook up it's a
girl yeah yeah it's a goal or a better
hook up with to get girls exactly like
Oh threesome oh man like that screws so
yeah we went on a tangent but I was
trying to get to yes is the police chief
in charge of Jesse smelts investigation
says there's more proof that he staged
the attack as a first photograph of the
backdated $3,500 Chucky page energy
brother he emerges the picture is just
so funny and so great but the chief the
police chief went on GMA this morning
and he has interviewed by I want to say
Robin Roberts who also did the interview
with Jesse like a day before it was
released that it was this huge hoax and
I remember that they're still under the
impression that this is real you could
tell Robin Roberts is like extremely
doubtful she's like well the police are
trying to help you like why don't you
just give over your phone right like and
he's like well you know I have personal
notes on there and songs everybody but
if you or hate crime like here's all of
my stuff
no like here's my vagina like oh like
really like please like get this person
off the street so she would sample but
he was being like an actor like you know
like people who doubt me like I don't
know if they'd be doubting me if I was
white and he'd say you know what I'm
like yeah maybe they wouldn't like he
was such a good hotshot mcquarters
you're right and now Robin Roberts is
the same person interviewing the police
chief who is just a class [ __ ] act
yeah when he showed up to the press
conference like
the day that it was blown up he was just
like and you know he's a police keep
chief of Chicago like one of the most
violent cities like they have such a
high crime rate totally he's like I've
come to these press conferences everyday
like nobody's here like I wish the
victims of gun violence would get as
much attention as this [ __ ] is getting
I mean it's not right it's so not right
and he ruined it for so many people and
it's just like and so the fact that he
felt that it was justified is even
sicker I hope he never works again ever
I hope he never gets another job what's
so weird is that power fired him right
they did but like they took kind of a
long time I feel like with me it's like
you get fired and your [ __ ] is packed up
for you and left at the door immediately
you're not allowed back on set like he
who bails himself out of jail and then
went to set for a few hours but think
about what you just said when we were
like talking about this where like we
both feel uncomfortable even like saying
one way or the other about this and like
there obviously is a right and wrong
like Empire being such a huge production
being a predominantly black production
like you want to support your own you
know your own actions like you don't
want to make the same mistake Chu and
jumping like nope you're fired and then
want it to be true then empires [ __ ]
right right then but I don't like that
everyone the proof is overwhelming but
everyone is still saying like if it
turns out feature remember so you're so
afraid cuz like how could this be fake
great and it's like it's a horrible
thing if an actual happen gay black men
who get beat up all the time it's not an
unheard-of thing but when it happens to
someone prominent you're like wow it
really puts you know into perspective
like how big of a problem it is well
that's the thing too is like if Jesse
small that were smart like he would have
known that a he would have had the
public behind him being a gay black man
and being like somewhat famous and to
like he could have not necessarily
gotten away with it but like there's
plenty of things to like hate crime
yourself or like even writing yourself
like a really ominous leg or what he did
but nobody better nobody cared he wrote
oneself a letter and nobody cared
but like either like with blood on it
some type of thread right sometimes I
play a bit something like I'm not
encouraging and I don't think it's a
right idea I'm just saying that II mean
every single stupid mistake you can
possibly make with the personal check
and you're an actor you know our
production is run I want to find this
quote that I read the same from Trevor
Noah yeah
I don't watch his show but I think maybe
and what [ __ ] sometimes what do you
think about I literally never heard like
heard him speak when he starts talking
with an accent I was unbelievably
confused um I think he is so smart I
think he's really funny obvious it's a
show good it's it's good it's different
like I just think it it changed a little
bit after John Stewart left cuz Jon
Stewart was so that for me right and
then I felt like when Jon Stewart left I
also kind of grew out of the show a
little bit like The Daily Show I felt
was very very good to get your news when
you're in your 20s when you're in your
late teens and that's the humor you want
right and now I've shifted to like last
week tonight with John Oliver and HBO
which feels a little bit more at all I
don't know John Oliver like works more
than two hours a week what does he do
during the other days I'm sure he's like
producing and writing the show like
intensely okay this is what Trevor Noah
said yes Sam um he finds the silver
lining um ah [ __ ] sorry I'm just trying
find this one quote oh here when they
started out it was a story about people
who hated justice Smollett because he
was black and gay but now people hate
him because he's an [ __ ] in other
words they're judging him on the content
of his character not the color of his
skin and that is progress that's true oh
my god it's a good point that's actually
a really good point and a hundred
percent even if he was even if Jesse
Smollett was a lesbian white lesbian you
know if he was me especially and I could
identify him and myself I'd still think
you were a [ __ ] or am yeah whatever you
are I don't care it's stupid
yeah even if you're just gay or just
black or try anyone committing your own
hate crime on yourself and then to do it
so stupidly and now I literally get the
message to be the opposite of what you
want right I can't think of anything
more damaging for that type of community
not only damaging anyone who literally
has the time to say Jeron hate crime is
an incredible [ __ ] loser
yeah you're a loser like oh dear Lee
you're not that emotionally wrecked from
from how you were treated on set or how
much you got paid twenty ten dollars of
state your own 20 grand an episode like
you know how much I purpose it for the
show yeah
thirty grand yeah which I make nothing
she pays me nothing no that's true slave
labor um so our final story is a segue
into talking all things Bravo I've been
meaning to talk about this on the show
because Lisa Rinna gave a particularly
snarky interview on Jenny McCarthy's
podcast I don't know she had a podcast
she just thinks it's really unbalanced
and she really kind of jabs at
Bravo the network and as someone who I
think is a representative of the Bravo
network I would love to hear your spots
yes this is what she said
saying that Lisa Vanderpump's did break
a lot of rules she didn't show up to the
promo of where they shot all the cast
photos yeah she was superimposed in she
didn't show up to the promo party you
have release party so Alyssa Rena just
doesn't see how it's fair quote the fact
that Bravo took no you know there were
no consequences and she was just able to
do that I think it's a really bad
example of women in the workforce Jenny
then asked Rena if she thinks Vanderpump
is treated differently by the network
the British Beauty is the real houses in
Beverly Hills superstar being one of the
only two members on the cast who started
out every season Lisa really responded I
do she has another show on Bravo it's
not fair it's not a fair playing field
I'm sorry it's just not so this room is
basically citing that if someone else
had done what Lisa Vanderpump did
someone who didn't show up to the photo
job it's a job she's a job she's she
refuses to film with a lot of the women
right now I think I don't know for sure
but towards the end of the season like
she's not in a majority the scenes with
most of the women right so Lisa Rinna
saying if someone else I like let's say
Erika Jayne did it and Erika Jayne
doesn't have another huge hit franchise
would she have gotten different
treatment does Lisa Vanderpump get
preferential treatment I don't think we
lose Davina from gets preferential
treatment I mean listen I think that she
is she's got two shows on Bravo she's
obviously an OG like people she's gonna
be under the his eye more than any other
person just because of what's happening
but I understand Rinna's point and it's
a good one to make and I don't think
that Bravo I mean I can't say for sure I
wasn't in every single meeting but I
can't imagine that Bravo was like yeah
it's okay at least it doesn't have to
show up for work right no what's your
job like we all take it very seriously
so now let me ask you and I have a
feeling the real houses in Beverly Hills
reunion has not been filmed yet correct
and it won't be filmed for a few months
correct
so I have a feeling that she's gonna
pull an Adrienne Maloof and not show up
cuz Adrienne Maloof could not take
accountability for her actions and then
also her divorce like it was just too
much Lisa Vanderpump is a lot of things
but she is not accountable I'm like all
these women coming for her like they
almost came for her with that Mexico
magazine thing and then Kyle at the last
minute turned around 11th hour yeah Kyle
is the only person who could really take
this Lisa Vanderpump reckoning all the
way and it seems like Kyle is on board
this time last time she almost got there
playing Fronteras with with Vanderpump
yeah so she's the only person who could
really take it all the way I do think
that there's a strong chance that Lisa
Vanderpump does not show up for the
reunion what wouldn't you guys do them
I I couldn't say for sure what we would
do then but it really would not be a
good look you get hurt find I'm sure you
do because there must be a contract of
how much you month like I've never seen
her specific contract so I can't say
legally one way or the other because
once I say it then people think it's
fact but it is still a job like no one's
just like you know if you want to come
into the office in it's not like me and
Annie like if you want to come into the
office today right two hours - it's like
no you are required to be filming when
you are here for for this amount of time
it takes months and months and months to
film I will say with that let the season
unfold okay let's see what happens let's
see what the public starts thinking of
it because I do think that's gonna sway
her whether you get her for sure because
you're still no matter what no matter
how famous or how rich you still care
about what your fans the court of public
opinion is a strong swing especially in
housewives 100% like it's her government
like that's what matters and if we're
not filming the reunion for another four
months three or four months that's
plenty of time for a public opinion or
trees sway and sway and and the other
women could like you know she could
solely you know ingratiate yourself to
her and immerse herself in their
hangings out and see you know slowly
kind of repair that relationship it
wouldn't be a good look though for you
not to show up there is a rumor that
they're doing another pump rules in
Vegas for her new restaurant pump in
Vegas can you confirm or deny those
rumors I can't confirm or deny but I
will say if Bravo's doing that that's a
great idea it is well yeah because like
scheana would get great like googling
over the Vegas oh my gosh there she go
they're like Jackie made a good point
though and it's like now that been
different boroughs is so successful
there's a bunch of other like spin-offs
people trying to be like lemons beach
club like workplace drama look the
reason wishes it was of course but
everyone wishes they were fan of her
pearls because Vanderpump rules from the
very beginning had what nobody else has
and they had that history they authentic
they worked there for seven years
without a TV show they worked there for
seven years without a TV show they all
have been friends for the better part of
a decade like they came in with drama I
couldn't you realize that rules have
that because it's a new restaurant
I mean maybe but if if there were people
that moved over from Sur Villa Blanca
right and they all have their own
relationships because like Heath and
Adam and he's like secondary characters
like I know who faith is like I know
exactly what you look like that she's
done other MTV shows from there like max
like there are those like
secondary characters cocina calorie
right Jesse Montana those exactly you've
created you've cast the secondary for a
reason you know like nobody cares about
them maybe but they might if they like
moved over backwards drama right because
season one Vanderpump was so different
than Season seven like morally so if you
get morally four pump roles Vegas I want
you're in like you are in we can bring
back the Jack and a sister and faith had
six which I like there's just so much
fodder they're so good that's so true I
knew it's me out how close Vegas is to
LA actually does have like a number of
employees it's just that like the four
seater 7p and magic girl I know I like
what justice for Peter why isn't he more
of a full-time cast member
I feel like cuz he's actually you know
when you talked about how you got mad at
me that I don't leverage my Instagram
more with what I do and I was like I'm a
professional and you were like okay
that's fair like you do have like a job
right you need to protect you can't be
in Andy's ass okay every two seconds I
mean you can I sort of feel like that's
like Peter like Peter is me where he's
like yeah I have a real he's a manager
like he probably gets pretty well yes
how he gets paid to being on episode dan
has a real job that's going to take him
farther than Gregor the TV show so he
doesn't wanna that's fair did you find
him attractive
no not like not at all I actually find
unattractive do you find him attractive
no because look like I get it to me
because he has long hair and he's yeah
he's like one nice guy like you know
you're up with people like you need to
do that for Peter no totally but like
there's something about Peter that I
just find like like who okay so if all
the guys on Vanderpump rules who would
you most want to hook up with and who
would you least want to have that I
would most want to hook up with Jack's
still not even Schwartz no honestly
Schwartz pisses me off so much he's such
a bad like husband and businessman and
like he's the hottest face lies but yes
he bothers me so much and honestly like
Katie is just such a woman and like such
a feels like renewer like honestly he's
just such a [ __ ] sometimes I can't
stand him I think Jax is so hot he's
back to season one Jack skinny skinny
jacks he's understood I want to say like
yeah I have met him countless times he
is so kind to me like when he doesn't
have to I love him he like I met him
once and he remembers me every time it
gives me kiss on the cheek and I'm just
like charmed by him I'm like like think
you are I'm Jax like if Jax was are
Kelly like you would
girl I mean I just I think you
understand I think the network like the
producers and editors I don't love him
and they always give him like a weird
edit even his proposal like it was a
little weird but like up there was a lot
of meaning behind it and they didn't put
that in at all I found out on watch
happens live when they were like oh well
it's just really special restaurant to
us because we used to go there all the
time or something with his dad you know
I'm spending all that extra money on the
ring like I don't know I just think he's
a little like his Emily like a weenie
woman eyes are like [ __ ] girls whatever
but but like a one-time hookup you'd
feel very yes and I do think at his core
he's actually a good person yeah no I
hey listen I actually really like him
like yeah like a genuinely nice guy and
thanks girls wise hookup Lala and who
would you least likely hope that was um
I think just personality wise like
Ariana would [ __ ] hate me Oh see I
would hook up with Ariana fo sho really
yeah in I think person like but then
looks wise I think after Lala I would
probably hook up with stuff yeah I love
something yeah I love Stassi yes now
she's so much better now than she was
season one like why she's been humbled
but like genuinely so that she's just
like nice off-camera and made the bed
the bogey her boyfriend is just so
[ __ ] he's a sweetheart for each other
ah I love their relationship I knew we
would spiral into a conversation and
they know you had you have to leave soon
so I just want to run through a couple
things with you five minutes for me I go
ahead okay
talk about Andy he's a dad now he's a
dad yeah we're at the baby shower you
were like fully like I names up in New
York went and the LA one oh okay well I
know you spoke to Jackie about the baby
shower but I wasn't here so we have to
talk about it yeah sorry testers if you
already heard it um and he has a father
Benjamin Allen I love the name first
well it's so presidential so after his
grandfather loved it yes Benjamin Allen
co-ed home Benny he's in wait wearing a
BabyBjorn yes he has he loved it he's
perfect for it I was like this is a
perfect like dad bod photo if you could
see like still looks good and buffed but
he's just got this little like nugget
him holding Walker yesterday with the
paparazzi feels great is it difficult
because I feel like and I read Andy's
book so I do feel like I know him
yeah um walk it's like was such a huge
part of Andy's life I think it's really
at the center of his universe but when
you have a child like that just your
priorities change do you think waka is
feeling like shafted no I think that
dogs are really empathetic like at first
I thought that too and Andy and I would
talk about it he's like I'm just not
gonna make a big deal of it like if you
feel like if you don't make a
to like force the relationship it kind
of happens naturally yeah anything dogs
really empathetic and they want to care
for anything that's like tinier than
them and there's this picture that Andy
showed me and like walk is kissing Ben's
like face and both of their legs snouts
and yeah I'm saying that his son has us
now yeah because I can't think of a
better word just like against each other
and it was like so cute and I've been
attacked by waka before so I'm
personally terrified but it was just
like so adorable I haven't seen any bad
behavior from either one of them and Ben
he's like the best baby ever so I don't
know if this is a wildly inappropriate
question and I'm sure that it is if I
have to preface it with that probably
but so um the surrogate yeah do we know
where like personally like are they
gonna maintain a relationship is it her
egg it's not her egg I don't know about
maintaining a personal relationship I
mean there's obviously like what was she
like she I haven't personally met her
I've talked to her before she's
perfectly lovely she is a professional I
mean this is something you're carrying
someone's future perfectly healthy made
everything did everything right it was
like a great pregnancy it's a Sarah
Jessica Parker's egg no it's not an S so
it's like we're never gonna find out who
the father of Mindy Kaling's baby is and
we're now we're gonna find out who the
mother of and easiest person I think
it's no it's not a famous person I think
it's really hard when you are famous
because especially if you have a donor
like a the public is just like ready to
jump on you in my day and it's not as JP
zag at all I am Telling You this
factually like not hers but let's just
say that it was like right and imagine
that that came out like people wouldn't
shut the [ __ ] up about it any time and
II was out possession a piece like you
could never have that like fully Normand
yeah right exactly I'm like you want to
do what's right for best so you went to
the East Coast baby shower yeah was it
very low-key what was it yeah where was
it it was a nanny's apartment was very
low-key it was very tame it was like his
closest friends there was probably 25 of
us there and we had one of those like
confetti cakes you know that Kelly Ripa
talks yes I was there open it up and
like all the candy spills out it was
nice it was like a catered thing we had
trained swanky it was like what I
thought
the housewife one was going like I
thought it was gonna be like a tasteful
luncheon you know what I mean and it
didn't turn out to me that at all well
the star is born' theme was so funny now
yeah the narrative that as a social
media consumer that was whether it was
sent to me was that Kyle Richards
oh geez hosted it yeah yeah after they
did that mean they paid for it yeah
after the Bravo didn't pay for any of it
Bravo didn't pay for any of the travel
we didn't film any of it like nothing
was paid for a bribe
all of them flew out themselves all the
solo you video Andy from live we did it
yeah cuz it was like you couldn't quit
and it was like so great but all that
was the housewives themselves you
through it like after the Como G
faithful which was December 20 announce
the baby after the show they were all
like we want to throw you a baby shower
and so it came together a month later
because the baby shower was on January
26 so that's why like not everyone could
be there we were probably missing like
six housewives like well Simone was
already you know snow tably
Lucia Vanderpump wasn't missing Lisa
Vanderpump we were serving down upon
Prozac right after she was there in
spirit and she wasn't happy that you
didn't do it at pump I have I I feel
like she would be happy we weren't doing
it really cuz it was there's so much
press around it like I hope it you know
but then she'd have to show up right so
was she she was in town I mean I assume
so I didn't know her schedule but he
wasn't there either but I think that
anything she's do good for that kind of
stuff Bethenny wasn't there she and her
prior appearance Kelly Dodd wasn't there
melissa gorga wasn't there Deandra
wasn't there Portia wasn't there cuz she
was pregnant fair Phaedra showed up that
was there sure was a gift I heard from
Nene - Andy yes yes and II love Phaedra
I love Phaedra Phaedra I like and I know
she did something incredibly [ __ ] up
and I should hate her for it 100% like
horrible watching her a demon totally
good plot I didn't think it she'll make
her way back but in the moment yeah the
bretton that Network had to do the right
thing because what she was accusing
Kenya was hard was horrible LuAnn wasn't
there she she had a show in Boston she
had a show and then yeah I think like
pretty much everyone else was like was
there so every woman every housewife was
technically invited yes what about like
a BB dresser like past housewives yeah
because then you don't really know where
to cut it off right like Carlton Gebbia
what do we have like a hundred and fifty
people like see how size right exactly
haven't like like even all Miami like
what are we inviting jokes do you want
to hear something so funny yeah so I
went to countess the lens show and you
know I'm sorry to blow up her spot cuz
I'm sure people are gonna go but do you
know how she ends her show no tell me
she goes just like the Real Housewives
of DC the show must come to an end how
funny is that I thought it was so clever
I love that like eager housewives jab at
each other like God
TV gold so speaking of in our housewife
jabs the real hot sub Jacqueline and
Jennifer both went to Milan show in
Jersey yeah I would love to hear your
thoughts on the new housewives in terms
of Jersey oh yeah okay I think Jennifer
I think Jackie is like super smart I
think she's really really fun she seems
like the most relatable like I just like
Jackie I really have nothing bad to say
about her jennifer is the most perfect
person for TV ever made I mean so much
and like I I'm from Jersey so like I
know exactly everything that they're
talking about like I grew up in the town
like next door to our Jennifer it's like
I have a palace and it overlooks Paramus
New Jersey and like if you know Paramus
New Jersey and listen I'm from Jersey
but it's just kind of like what are you
looking at like it's not like oh I've
central park west of Lamar right right
overlooking like the Hudson in the park
like yes not like that like you're
overlooking the mall I definitely it's
just so funny I love Jennifer I think
she's great for TV she's perfect Lissa
said something should she came on the
show she said like the most insightful
thing she was just like people think
she's like a crazy drunk Jennifer but
it's like she has been like cooped up in
her house for 10 years like her kids are
her life her husband she takes her
marriage really seriously like she's
taking Turkish she takes her mommy
duties really seriously yes and this is
like the first time where she has like a
friend of girls where they go on trips
and you drink and it's like liberating
and that's why Melissa was like when I
came on the show like I was Joe Joe Joe
Joe Joe what can I do to make gentleman
have sex with Joe let me make Joe for
the kids Oh Joe and the second I like
was liberated into like womanhood and my
own business she was like its addicting
and thankfully Joe like supports it but
that's why a lot of the women from the
show get divorced because their husbands
aren't used to them like having this new
life when they were like they were
housewives right none of them are
housewives and that's what's happening
with Jennifer she's on this like
liberating like vacation yeah and I
don't think she's gonna get divorced
because I think her and her husband like
we really have a good marriage and I do
think he loves the show he's wearing his
branded eight in plastic surgery like a
scrub like they're Turkish likely to get
about marriage but I do like I respect
that
I do like he said like it took me ten
years to like my goal there's past like
10 years of being married was to keep
the tequila away from her that was like
that's so accurate it's so Jordan so
yeah like that's so true like I'd like
everything I like both the house for
some reason I can't get behind Jackie
and I'm not sure why because everything
she's saying she's correct like when
she's arguing with Teresa who sings
like Teresa's being so unreasonable this
the reunion she's so irrational she was
like you're on a choices show yeah she
was being nuts
yeah and Jackie was saying all the right
things but I'm just like stop I just for
some reason like I can't get behind
Jackie I can't support her and I don't
know why I think that like let her
develop like to me it's coming up a
little bit of Carrie rod Z well if yeah
where she's like she's very smart she's
a journalist she takes herself very
seriously were like high horse a little
bit of that but she's just like so
unlikable I don't know why he's likeable
because she's kind of different than the
rest of them but let's see if she gets
herself into like more drama you know
she comes back yeah things unfold
because I think what she starts being
really Jersey that's when you're gonna
fall in love with her right that's what
you wanna see Jackie put it so perfectly
Jackie it's a really interesting way of
like analyzing housewives in a
meaningful way because I did think it
was odd that like she's on TV for five
minutes and the first thing she does is
when you're night with her sister after
15 years like and you don't hear her on
the phone like that's what I did think I
was like huh weird and Jackie was like
cuz you want to know why like we don't
care about her yet she's a first things
in person like heard like and hers like
we barely care about her let alone her
relationship with her sister like we
needed it to develop more so then we
become invested like now I'm so invested
in Margaret cuz I absolutely love her
and I love her husband and I think the
dynamic with Jan is so weird and Brett
like I want to hear more exactly exactly
so like let her breathe a little bit
like let it really I mean even Dolores
the storyline this year I felt like he
was even more I mean Dolores and
Margaret are like my favorite me to her
like but even just seeing like Frankie
jr. and seeing like Frank and de l'eau
my god he's so attractive Frank and
Dolores is relationship like really come
to fruition like last year I didn't I
wasn't as concerned with it but yes
you're I'm like I just want you to like
be together forever and I love this and
I love both of you because you care more
you become sad that's it and like with
Jackie I just thought it was like a
weird thirsty thing to do on your first
season right fair but it was like a Hail
Mary
like I want everyone to like me let me
throw my sister but it's also like you
know these are good opportunities for
other and the public to see that like
this and it could be ten years ago 15
years like maybe this is good message
it's a good message and it's important
and we'll see how it unfolds but the
reunion is like so again it's so second
part is gonna be well I get screeners
because I'm special and yeah I live for
screeners like I feel so cool and
special knowing things I I try not to
watch like until the day of because I
don't want to accidentally spill
something on the show okay see that's i
watch like ten episodes ahead and I'm
like
Oh have you not seen when they Oliver
into a robot they're like why that's
what Jerry O'Connell said he was like I
got so many screeners maybe faster like
pace yourself yeah because you want to
keep into the zeitgeist like in the
moment you spoil something you're like
you're dead in the water
yeah and then they take your screeners
away exact so I'm behaving exactly okay
well thank you teryn sorry for keeping
you so late
no thanks for having me I love an follow
car Pete Aaron on Instagram even though
she doesn't thirst out as much as I
would like her to buy my make her take a
picture with me today and everyone go
like and leave a nice comment about her
hair yes please um and that's all we got
scheduling update I am headed to Utah
because I'm just [ __ ] tired and I'm
just not feeling great I'm listening to
my body I know bloggers always say that
oh my you guys are so full of [ __ ] but
like I woke up yesterday and I was like
I need to listen to my body because I
just have been working a lot and I just
I'm not I'm not doing okay like mentally
I'm fine but physical but physically I'm
not so we're gonna be doing podcast
episodes for the rest of the week
we're gonna livestream some some just
don't worry about it we will take care
of you when you wake up everyday there
will be a podcast waiting for you I feel
really lucky to be the last thing you
see before your vacation I know it's
what's that Taylor's trekker I had to
cancel on her just because I'm really
like I'm not doing okay yeah you're not
I'll let Taylor know you she didn't send
her condolence and out of Sam's where
she was happy like less work yeah I know
she's great I don't know okay so we will
see you guys tomorrow have a great week
bye
you